hey guys welcome back comedy store
podcast uh i'm rick ingram i'm eleanor
we got mr shore mr short let me get here
test test yeah okay
i never like using headphones i don't
either i like to keep one ear out i
don't know why maybe i was strangled in
a previous but thanks for um you know
thanks for having me and i'm i'm glad so
are you guys the official host we are
the officials you're like regis and
kelly or like kelly and mike or whatever
i like to think of sag and vanna there
you go yeah i i just that's that's
actually my new goal
is to just when say jack dies or retires
i want to i want to be the guy who has
like a fortune how long have you guys
been co-hosting together
um two three months yeah so how many of
you guys done together
um probably eight eight or something
like that yeah so you guys should build
a graphic with the communist logo so
it's like so is is who gets the first
billing
i usually put rick's it doesn't matter i
think yeah i mean rick and eleanor right
he's been doing a little bit longer yeah
so the rick and eleanor podcast show
comedy comedy strip pocket with the logo
and your guys yeah and then we like to
take pictures with people and put them
on there too for a video you guys do it
i'll just sit here
but i'm just saying you know it'd be
cool to have you guys are the official
host because no one like i didn't know
that you guys were the host so you guys
just told me just now and i don't think
anyone else does really so if you no i
don't think so no because you guys just
kind of
fell into it he was hosting for a while
yeah and then you merged into it so now
if this is doing it every week yeah so
this is good so you guys should you know
people are willing to do the podcast uh
more now now that eleanor's on like
before i'd ask you because it's more
official yeah i'd ask people they'd be
like no i don't think so right now i
agree and that i think you asked me once
and i was like i don't know
like let's go to the basement and
they're like wait what yeah there's a
basement yeah that really freaks people
out before there's i'm not going all the
way upstairs because we were in that the
room opposite of landing patch or
whatever so now that's right are you
still up there or is your that's landing
patch that's what we can't expect we
can't i like to be private
physically oh right yeah i mean i don't
want people showing up in the middle of
creeping yeah freaking out over you like
steve kravitz will show up hey paulie
what's going on do you like hockey polly
no steve's great steve is great and he
goes every sunday still right or no do
you see him once in a while or you don't
know alfred doesn't really let him in
okay smart the last time i was there i
had to write my name down so i was like
oh okay
i guess we're keeping names hey you know
uh dice said dice said uh he said uh if
it wasn't for mitzi shore she would have
passed away a long time ago
oh with her disease with my mom's yeah
parkinson's absolutely because like and
you know better than anyone like you
were very close with her like when she
was here love her like yeah like
if it wasn't for myth being my mom
because she's had parkinson's for so
long yeah or her nervous thing whatever
it is yeah she don't like that word yeah
i know she don't like that word but it's
a form of parkinson's exactly it's in
the fam parkinson's family right but um
yeah she's really strong but she's
healthy at the same time so it's like
like she looks fantastic right i think i
was there like right before her birthday
the week before her birthday so by her
eyes everything she's so full and she
spoke to us a couple times like it was
just crazy
it was still scared you know you should
tell paulie what you did uh argus i mean
i'm sorry not argus don barris made him
do argus to her oh yeah and it freaked
her out a little bit this is probably
like eight or eight nine years ago or
something she was here and he was like
oh come on come on let's mitchy will
love it i'm just like all right and i
was still drinking so it was easy to
convince me to do anything right and uh
so i walked over doing full argus and
she just stared at me and then after
about a minute of bombing of doing argus
4 i was like oh no this isn't going good
and then she just goes that's nice go
away that's hilarious i was like
all right that's my out and then i
walked away just like i hope i'm not
banned can i i want to ask you like
when you first started doing stand-up
what was that like i mean your mom being
mitsy sure
how the hell did you present that well i
always knew i was gonna do it ever since
i was like little little yeah cause the
comics always said you're always funny
always yeah i was always like oh i'm
gonna do it but my my answer to myself
was well when am i gonna start so i
started when the s.a.t papers were
coming
sent back in high school at the
beginning of 12th grade oh okay yeah
the beginning of 12th grade is when i
took it really seriously like like i
said it's like okay now let's [ __ ] do
it wow serious though like really i get
like i do
i am in my life do you have to do the
open mic and stuff or do no i stayed
away from the comedy store for at least
two years old factory yeah i did a lot
factor for jamie yeah for a long time
and it was just like by choice you just
didn't want it yeah by choice
because you wanted to get good before
you yeah i didn't want to showcase for
her unless unless i had like two years
under my belt that's so crazy today even
you had to showcase oh yeah and it was a
nightmare it was terrible how was your
showcase it was terrible
how many times did you showcase before
you got past well i'll tell you the
story i know this story really well
because i for the last two years i've
been putting together a documentary in
my life right so i've been reliving
i've been reliving and interviewing
everyone that's been in my life since i
was born okay so i know all the stories
very clear
so what happened was wait what was the
question again just what was your
showcase okay okay the showcase yeah
yeah the showcase
so it was louis anderson and it was paul
mooney and they were in the back and you
were probably serving how long have you
been uh 93. i don't know i was here no
no okay
so um what year was it when you
showcased i think it was
88 okay you know 88
and i did my show and after i ended with
pop locking i was very into dancing okay
i brought out my big boombox and i
played freakazoid
and this i mean 88 that's that's that's
priming for yeah
yeah and i started popping and i was
really good i was coached by a guy named
sugarpop if you know anything about pop
locking in the 80s sugarpop was the best
popper period he brought pop locking to
la he was in every michael jackson video
he was in thriller he was in beat it he
went on tour with lionel richie damn he
was like the [ __ ] like
no one [ __ ] he was in every like
like he toured with prince
he was like [ __ ] but not like in the
back of prince like with prince right so
he taught me and i used to bring him up
to my house
and my mom man i met my mom so that was
the first thing so i did my dancing
and then after
i go up to her and i'm like how did i do
and she said stick with the
dancing yeah so then um so there was a
lot of friction there was a lot of
friction between me and my mom because
she wanted me to go to college
and um and uh you know and i don't know
she was like pushing me to do stand up
or whatever
and then i just i just um
you know i just uh
there was friction it was really bad and
that was at the time where sam kennison
took me under his wing and i became very
very close with sam and sam was on drugs
and he was doing a lot of coke and he
was [ __ ] out of his mind i mean the
comedy store now is like so mellow right
yeah i mean back then it was it was like
you come here it was scary it was like a
scary place yeah you know what i mean
like you didn't people are always gonna
happen
cocaine was like a very big deal yeah
now
some people smoking pot and drinking but
there really isn't a drug scene no yeah
so i was hanging out with sam a lot so
that's when you know it got really bad
with me and my mom
and i just i had to become pretty much i
had to become famous
on like mtv and like start working as an
actor and get a following here before
she actually made me a paid regular
really wow
that's tough so well i can't understand
her wanting you to go to college also
knowing like seeing all the comics
knowing what you go through you don't
want your kid going down the path
especially with all the drugs that are
around she's like i don't want to
encourage my kids but i was always like
i mean you guys know me pretty well i'm
not a druggie i'm not [ __ ] up i'm not
you know i never i never really was i
partied but i did throw some great
parties though yeah
i mean vagina's another thing but at the
time no but we have our addictions yeah
exactly
no but i always kind of watch what not
to do through all these people that are
here you learn from their mistakes yeah
i learned from their mistakes they were
the best teachers because look at argus
i mean i look at argus and i feel really
sad for him actually because he's so
talented and and he's he's i don't want
to say he's so good looking but he's
like a really good looking guy you know
he's like america yeah yeah now he
obviously is he's older but yeah but
back in the day dude he was a [ __ ]
star
period end of story a [ __ ] star dude
yeah but he but drugs drugs [ __ ] them
up right so i saw that so much and it
was just like yeah it was just gross
dude and i you know uh so yeah do you
remember like your whole life you've
been at the comedy store right since i
was four yeah obviously yeah from
wisconsin
yeah
damn
that's unbelievable but then didn't you
work in westwood as well yeah was that
where you wanted to cook yeah no what
happened was there is a i wanted to get
a salt this one was 14 years old and i
wanted to get a saltwater fish tank
okay good natural no because james bond
had saltwater fish as obsessed with
james bond films like obsessed because
he got [ __ ] yeah you know what i mean
who got more [ __ ] in movies than james
bond no but not a lot of people period
like it was james bond that was it and
james bond had salt water so i thought
to myself if i get a big saltwater fish
tank with saltwater fish the ladies will
follow you can get some vagina
so i love that that
that was your desire mom i asked my mom
i'm like can you get him she's like no
she goes if you want it you have to work
for it
so she says you can be shorter to cook
at the store in westwood wow so i worked
there and that's where i made my money
and then i eventually got my saltwater
fish tank at 14 you were running into
the kitchen running it too fast and
everybody do that serving like 2 300
people like these mexican dudes they
don't have [ __ ] dude
and the stuff that they're making is
disgusting like chicken fingers yeah
gross i put like love into my [ __ ] i
made like really good hamburgers i would
like spend time like like marinating it
like in the afternoon and make it great
and people that's awesome freak people
be like this is really good well i'm
like a really good cook right now i'm
always a really good cook that's great
yeah i did not know that yeah um
i love cooking so i love that you would
marinate the beef and everything like
that because now they do they just throw
things in a fridge frozen it's all
frozen everything's so fast right yeah
someone some i i had a friend i i guess
he's not really a friend but somebody
went to high school with us out here and
he's like how do they prepare the
chicken fingers
well they remove them from the bag
cuisine i got to be honest if i was
waiting tables here i'd be pissed as
[ __ ] i hate it
let me ask you something sure
um
so because it's weird for me to see you
as a comic yes you know what i mean just
because i've known you for you know
since you know i've known you since i
was a waitress here for 12 years you're
here for so long serving why didn't you
do stand up then i don't know that's so
weird i never had any interest in doing
stand up at all and then you just
clicked or someday i think afterwards
guys guys listening eleanor who's the
host of the show
she was a server here
like the number one server from 1993
to 2005. 2000 that's a long time 12
years she ran the show when i got here
she's in charge of the all of the
waitresses did a lot of yelling yeah
because i remember when comics would uh
what when comics would do something to
anger the waitresses
you you felt the wrath of eleanor that's
right so you
ready so you quit eventually so after
freddy soto passed in all honesty i i
quit because i got engaged today
speaking of him just really quick yes
because i'm digging into my documentary
i have footage of him oh really like old
footage like when he said driving my
mom's limo oh my god that's so
crazy to the [ __ ] la jolla dude
that's sick dude that's awesome and he
looks like awesome okay go on yeah but
after freddy passed because freddie was
my best friend and after he passed
for years they would be like you should
be doing stand-up because i would hold
court in the kitchen and just [ __ ]
around but that's just how i was like i
didn't think silly yeah i didn't think
oh stand up i should be doing stand up
i'm like no
that's not easy to do and it's a sad
life kind of yeah
now i know that's not clear for real
it's really not and then and so i
completely get your mom protecting you
from it because to me i'm like [ __ ] if i
knew about i'm an idiot i knew 12 years
left came back as a standout yes and
then started touring with my ex-fiance
like that's even weirder i know i'm
creepy no but the whole thing just
deciding to to do it to do it yeah and
even dice was like what now you're going
to do stand-up like i've known you all
this time domi rare is one of my closest
friends they're like now you're but the
thing is also the thing is you've gotten
good fast though because of that because
of the college i went to it's the
greatest years of and why yeah i mean
watching comedy
fox 2 is another thing
like
he you know was acting and doing so much
you know
film work and tv stuff so when he
decided in late in his life to become a
stand-up it happened quicker for him
than most yeah yeah and he's such a
great writer but i remember him from you
and the parties and stuff like that from
waiting tables all the years all your
buddies
broiler or whatever
is that face
no there's like a bunch of probably like
the best friends in all honesty i don't
even say it like you're not here but you
always had like the best friends and the
best parties we used to [ __ ] throw
big parties
every time i know it's a mistake because
i like to check with my brother to see
if it's uh
is peter listening peter you're
listening yeah
they want to throw a wild party here
peter would let us throw a party i think
we'd have to sell tickets though we'd
have to
if we if we got a guarantee 300 tickets
sold i think he'd do it oh yeah i would
say but do you remember the material you
used when you showcase other than the
pop blocking yeah angel
wrote a lot of my stuff angel salazar
yeah he yeah he um
because you know i was like you know i
was like were people kissing your ass
because you were mitzi's kid like were
they trying to help you out were they
helping you out because they knew you
said you
i got along with everyone it was never i
was never like the owner-son [ __ ] it
wasn't like that right
i was part of their life you know what i
mean they all raised the cool kid yeah
well they all raised me so it's like
you know angel you know wrote my first
joke he said uh i grew up in i grew up
in beverly hills my mate's mexican my
mailman is black my gardener's japanese
a day at my house like a day at the dmv
was like my first joke
that's amazing i don't think i ever
heard that yeah it was uh pretty bad
all my original jokes were terrible
impressions and jokes about being from
kansas so right i mean that's far
superior to
what i was starting with
yeah so it's just one of those things
that developed you know on stage you had
like the best people at your disposal to
when you started doing stand-up like to
even ask for advice
going angel salazar is like he was the
man yeah
unbelievable i love i still see him on
the east coast once in a blue moon yeah
we work in vega uh
atlantic city sometimes um but yeah he's
terrific and then you had kennison
alan stephen raves about you yeah i love
allen how old were you when
started
taking you around
or you were a teenager or were you older
it was like uh it was
i'd say 80s
okay so you're like 18. 17 18.
unbelievable and then you get to tour
yeah i toured when i opened them for a
while yeah you did the outlaw thing or
something i did the outlaws in vegas i
toured with him there but then he took
me on the road
with bill kennison on a bus and you know
cruising around
but my documentary dude honestly my new
one is going to freak the [ __ ] out of
freak people i can't wait to see it's
like done in such a cool way it's done
through all audio
so i have over 50 interviews i've
already recorded that's basically it
takes place in the 70s 80s and 90s
and it's all done through audio and old
photos and old videos
but every because everyone sounds the
same but everyone looks different oh
yeah so you know when i when cr when
chris rock when chris rock
when chris rock is um
have him come in when chris
ian could be my co-host oh nice you
could be my co-host on my my interview
ian edwards ian edwards is here ladies
and gentlemen so anyways the point is is
that when people what's up bro
what's up when people when people speak
everyone everyone
sounds the same right but everyone looks
different so that's why you're in the
you're in these eras
and i got everyone i mean this
documentary it's like it's like my
version of the oj case like that's
murder murder
suicide
drugs
i mean you know fame uh you know
prostitution
abortion
[ __ ] you know all this [ __ ]
molestation like all that [ __ ] yeah i
think but i didn't do any of it it's all
the [ __ ] around me right are you
narrating it
no it's uh interesting no no i i uh uh i
do some
i talk about but it's mostly other
people talking about it
and it's about your life or about the
comedy it's my life okay you're like at
the comedy store obviously no it's just
part of it oh okay no it's i mean
there's so much that went on outside of
here absolutely in my life i mean the
[ __ ] that i seen is insane beverly hills
high school do you know anything about
beverly hills high school oh yeah yeah
who did you go to high school kids went
there i went with oh yeah but i'm
telling it back then though no back in
those days
they had some different stories thank
you
thank god
i went i my first best my best friend in
school was this black kid named eddie
washington okay and he used to live
across the street from the comedy store
if you go across you from the economy
store it's the mondrian yeah right right
there it used to be projects
like gnarly [ __ ]
so he was like my best friend used to
sleep over my house my mom took a man
and the whole thing i interviewed him
okay you know what i mean and that's
great like he was like my best friend so
he tells the whole story about you know
the comedy store back in the 70s and the
whole thing well they're
like crazy or they're famous
like people who are now famous going to
beverly hills
when i was um one of my another best
friend when i went to hawthorne which is
beverly hills high school was like was a
high school and then there's four
there's four kind of junior highs okay
there's elrodale there's horace mann
there's beverly vista and hawthorne they
say author yeah you went to hawthorne
okay hawthorne isn't that far hawthorne
no that's no
it's not the city oh
yeah
so my friend with this kid sean kehoe
was one of my best friends his dad was
like a [ __ ] like an irish gangster
who was best friends with oj
and oj was always at the house
so sean
when i i met oj in miami with dice and
one of the craziest things about meeting
him was that he asked me he's like see
tour with dice who else you tour with i
said i'm not going on the road with
paulie shore right now and he's like i
know paulie i've known polish since he
was a kid
so then he spent like 10 minutes telling
me these stories where i'm like
i think he's lying and that's what i
kept thinking when i was like i think
he's i think he's lying about knowing
paulie so that i think he's cool yeah
but i thought it was but now he really
and then and then smokey robinson's kid
barry robinson
i was basically him so i was very close
with smokey
when we were kids so whatever it's just
that's my point is there's so many
stories outside the store and they all
came and told stories yeah i got
everyone over 50 awesome
and i gotten comedians that people think
are dead right now i got them
like i hunted everyone down who do they
think is dead
oh four fingers yeah lenny schultz isn't
he like in the south somewhere no he's
in florida south florida yeah yeah i was
thinking actually tennessee or somewhere
about florida he lives in like in miami
good catch still awesome sorry i'm sorry
who was the south and i just because
though but he's really funny
a lot of people don't even know who he
is yeah he was
comic he was in the 70s yeah but he's my
favorite yeah he's like one of those
funny funny guys um
but also
i forgot my question rick it's your
question it's your turn dude it's my
turn just stand there bro
now that's your question it's on your
phone yeah we got to ask ian's what was
my boring non-famous don't know anybody
don't forget ian did paulie bring you
into the club
how did you get to the comedy story did
you really yes i remember someone said
black people i love black people paulie
when you say i love black people it
sounds fake just don't say it
you got to keep that secret yeah just
blacks and asians they go crazy i love
[ __ ] amazing girls are guys
it sounds more racist
because adds more racism we do have a
lot of thai people here remember your
mom would only hire tai which is amazing
no because they're
the best workers honestly did you see
that
documentary on netflix no mm-hmm you
know who he is right this is the surfer
he's the dj oh he's the dj with the long
hair steve aoki
oh i've seen the photo the billboards he
does it's a good documentary you know
who his dad was his dad discovered
benihana's
oh i hate benny hannas
dude i'm sorry i get the right that's
her that's her one thing that's
bringing it up
but uh like mexican food to me it runs
right through it's awful i hate it i
could never afford benihana so i don't
know i go with other people i sleep
around sorry they pay for it
right ian nothing amazing did you
showcase for uh mitzi or tommy mitzi
tommy was there
and then uh
i just did something with paulie didn't
you do like a sketch sketch movie dvd or
something yeah yeah sketch movie okay
natural boring natural boring comics
right
what it was and then uh then then they
hooked it up it came his mom was there
and uh were you scared of her
no i was just like just trying to get in
the club and i knew how to perform so i
just right did a set i don't even think
i did good that night but she was like
she's like
before yeah she could tell she didn't
[ __ ]
you know who i brought over to see to my
mom because i was very like me and my
mom were very close
like super close like i remember when
there was the the uh the was it fat
tuesdays was next door sure that was for
years oh yeah i was very close and with
robin harris oh yeah you guys remember
yeah yeah
you remember robin harris
i don't know rob hilarious yeah you
would love robin hood he's [ __ ]
hilarious tomorrow so i saw him i saw
him on fat tuesday i'm like i go i go to
dude i get him i run in the backstage
i'm like what are you doing on this show
dude
oh my god
this is the guy that loves black people
what do you hang out with these people
from here
my favorite people why are you hanging
out with my favorite people i'm like
this is this is this is not you know
this is cool and all but come right
don't come to the other side
we have a big secret going on over here
whoever was supposed to go up for my mom
next
and i'm like on a regular lineup not
even a show no it's like uh it was a
monday night oh okay i was like wow
that's yeah and i was like i'm like this
is the guy mom you gotta see this game
wow what's going on i'm like mommy's
[ __ ] hilarious and she he goes and
she died she was loving it and then i
moved i got i got out of the booth and i
put robin right next to my mom and my
heart sunk and i was like yeah i'm like
he's great and then we started giving
them spots i don't know that's oh yeah
because back then
open mic night the showcase nights were
sunday monday and tuesdays
mondays no sundays yeah sundays but then
right after that yeah right after that
he got into spike lee's movies yeah yeah
oh okay he's [ __ ] you got a [ __ ]
yeah
like right after like he was getting
huge and then he was in house party the
movie he was a dad he had a special out
there's gonna make it now i feel like
i'm gonna have a heart attack
baby kids i love baby kids
that's awesome wait so when did you do
your first movie wait you had the mtv
thing first right let's go back to my
thing with him no with him it was uh
so ian
what how how i brought an ian was
basically uh tommy tellerino who is his
writing partner right right yeah at the
time yeah yeah at the oh he fired him
he's like at the time not anymore [ __ ]
that guy i've had a writing partner a
long time well you guys were writing
together yeah yeah what show were you
writing on we did the boondocks together
and before that
like uh we did some some sitcom that
lasted six episodes okay but you guys
were writing and i was hooked up with
tommy first no i think it was we had the
same we were at the same agency oh yeah
gersch bernie bernie yeah yeah krusty
bernie sanders
bernie specter bernie spector
yeah whitney cummings talks [ __ ] about
him a lot dude
a lot of people talk [ __ ] is he still is
he still accepting clients because i
need anybody guys
we're looking i'll take anyone i don't
care how crusty they are clean them
he wasn't i don't know if he was a
stoner but he was just kind of like
whatever yeah bernie must have had money
of course because he because he yeah
was he a partner or was like he that no
he was just an agent yeah okay so we
hooked up through bernie and then once i
saw him i saw him i put him up right
away to see him first i think we did
natural
born comics first yeah yeah oh yeah
sketches yeah we wrote so you were just
writing you weren't performing stand up
no i don't know i was doing i i just
wanted to stand up here right but i
wasn't at the store yet yeah yeah right
so i i got him hooked up with my stuff
we went down to miami him and tommy
wrote him and tommy wrote some sketches
we did stand up it was me
you already shafir kirk fox and who else
i think that was it that was the improv
there's four of us yeah and we did the
improv that's a great
yeah and then from there
and then from there uh once that was
finished then we came here and then we
got it so you saw him perform in miami
yeah yeah got it well i remember talking
i had already seen his videos if you
google
ian edwards he's [ __ ] all over oh
yeah you've been doing this a while yeah
new york for a long time we don't know
how old you are we've just two years
i've been doing it you know what i'm
saying
i remember
when tommy was the talent coordinator
here and he would always talk about how
uh
how
he was he had a fear that you were going
to take his job that you wanted to be
the talent coordinator and then
i'd be like i don't think paulie wants
to be the talent coordinator he wants to
be the town and then he'd be like well
he's got comics already he brought in
ian edwards i'm like
the first time i watched him i was like
damn this guy is [ __ ] good
i didn't realize how nervous you made
tommy i think i told you i would have
enjoyed
the podcast [ __ ] we did yeah what's up
it's coming out on crackle bro oh the
license all of them finally the one last
year yeah
well you're jamaican
i just see jamaicans as normal people
yeah i don't feel the need to say i like
him as a when we're over here remember i
asked you a million questions before i
went because i did the kid rock cruise
and how was that oh it was unbelievable
it was the [ __ ] best but i was the
only comic but we went to jamaica and
that was the highlight of the trip for
me and my boyfriend we went he he's
obsessed with bob marley so we went to
marley's house and we heard all these
great stories just amazing they take you
on the tour up to nine mile it was so
cool and he kept giving kids money and
they were [ __ ] chasing the bus it was
awful
he's throwing twenties out i'm like babe
why twenty save them for me give those
kids a dollar you just treat them like
strippers yeah right making it rain
that's for me and benihana
i'm just kidding i don't like that place
so
so you showcase here and
killed and scared the [ __ ] out of the
town tommy was scared mitzi liked it oh
yeah tommy protected me like me all the
time yeah mitzy was here wow what did
she say oh i didn't i didn't really talk
to her did i i said hi
and i said thank you and then i walked
over to the top
bro yeah something like that
get your hands off my mom's knee yeah
something like that it's like a weird
interaction
i think that was always the plan when
mitsy called me over to talk to her
that was the worst
i ever felt my life because i was
positive she was just gonna be like
never perform here again
but then the rest of the times when i
perform for her she would just be like
good and i was like sweet yeah but the
best is how i met rick oh
please
sherman oh yeah i did i met paulie
before i ever came to the comedy store
uh i was tell the whole story it's
hilarious dude i don't i don't even
really remember the story
with your [ __ ] parents my parents
kansas
yeah
we went to hawaii for i think it was
thanksgiving or something and uh
so it was probably like 15 years ago
right yeah i was i was
19 maybe 20. you're just a white kid
with your white family in hawaii yeah
period
shorts
yeah yeah
you're at the sheraton hotel yep
sheridan hotel and you're there just
and you know and you're kind of putting
your lotion on
and you look over and what do you look
over somebody's creepy i saw paulie with
babes how many i thought you said i was
just with the one babe
i just know there was a really
attractive girl
one of the more probably one of the most
attractive girls i'd ever seen being
from kansas clearly i just remember
being like this dude gets ass yes and uh
yeah i mean i
did you know it was paulie like oh yeah
obviously but i definitely knew it was
paulie and i was i just remember being
extremely nervous
and uh i i i think i said hi to him are
just like hey i'm a fan
and he he gave me that look like dude
i'm with the hot chick get the [ __ ] away
from him
don't shock me
white guy
that's funny that's the first time i met
him yeah so did you remember he reminded
you he reminded me i didn't i don't know
he doesn't remember every creepy white
kid that stares at him from the face i
was a creepy white kid that met you too
outside the comedy store i came here
before i moved here i came here on
vacation with my boyfriend mario
naturally and you were filming outside
with todd lemisch it was something for
mtv yeah and maybe don barris probably
and
uh mario was like we gotta get a picture
we gotta get pictures [ __ ] paulie
short we got a [ __ ] picture so i
asked mario sounds like a smart dude
from that impression a lot of smart guys
i'm not sure if you guys noticed yeah
yeah
stellar
you're into nerds we get it yeah
you have kids oh i don't have any kids i
would never carry the full term um sorry
ricky i'm just saying i don't know
no apologies to me i don't do that
no kids but uh anyway so i had this cute
little half top on and i thought i was
all sexy so he's like you go talk to him
and he literally pushed me off to
[ __ ] take a picture
so i took a picture and then you
wouldn't take one with mario
that's that's the right move you don't
take a picture with the dude that's
weird really it was like a collage i
made the first year i moved here and
then collages are done one of my first
my first class that's the girliest thing
i've ever ever ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever ever did
a collage but i did it on cardboard cut
it into a heart probably still gay
collages are awesome that's what you do
in the 80s and 90s
it was the 90s and then i had it on the
shitty piece of cardboard and so my
first ex-fiance he put it in a frame for
me so it's like stuck there
that's so now i when i first met paulie
i think
i'll send it to you you'll love it it's
so weird because i'm just like
nervous why is he making my first
interaction with paulie at the comedy
store uh i was an employee here and uh
i was standing in the back and i i'm
sure you guys never noticed but i i
talked [ __ ] about people sometimes no no
no no
obviously i'm different now but back
then i was this little [ __ ] talker and
uh i was i was a paid regular already
but i was angry that i didn't get stage
time
and uh this comic named jeremy dingle
would get stage time and so dingle got
off stage
he was a he was an odd one i'm fixated
dingle got off stage and he had just
bombed doing that weird [ __ ] that he had
a singlet yeah did he have this and uh
and so i thought hey i'm going to make a
name for myself paulie's standing by
paulie's going to think i'm cool because
i'm going to bully this guy
so i started talking [ __ ] about him and
then paul was just like dude he's a paid
regular he's been paid regular longer
than you have
and then it probably completely shut
down in my mind it's gonna be like me
being like dingle you're a [ __ ] loser
and then paulie's gonna be like we're
both cool and he's a loser
and instead he just shut me down he
almost went to tony hinchcliffe route i
tried yeah yeah and he just he was like
no you respect the other paid regular so
i was like oh yeah that's true oh okay
that's cool but then i feel like i got
paulie back when i started mocking argus
i brought you on the road with me before
a long time yeah right yeah i was like
23.
you would have me do argus on the radio
oh yeah i would do like that always be
like paulie we want to play trivia you
ready to trivia and he'd be like no
argus will do it
and i was great at it and they'd always
look at me like who's argus because i'm
acting like this idiot like i wouldn't
be rick at all the whole time funny
because like sometimes i'll like go back
i remember like i forgot it was i think
it was the weasel is it the weasel in
brooklyn or no new york in upstate new
york there's like and he wouldn't have
me on again because i brought like
openers with me
and like my openers like like like
like sandy would do like tommy
impressions or yeah like sometimes i
just set them up because their their
questions are so i don't know well it's
that morning radio yeah the morning
radio thing
and i wanna can i wanna i wanna give and
let the other people like get involved
like let sandy do his thing and or you
just wanna laugh yeah that's funny just
take
but i think sandy's funny though it is
yeah
and with the argus thing i remember that
like they were very clearly gonna try
and like stump you like that was their
plan because they're asking these
ridiculously absurd questions about like
oh this chilean dictator no and then
i being a huge dork knew the answers and
as argus as you well obviously we're
talking general pinochet
that shuts down [ __ ] dale and
tammy in the morning or whatever it was
like
i love that you knew the answer they
were not happy that i knew all the
answers bring it on let's keep doing it
i'm looking i'm looking at rick now he
looks like he got bad face yeah the
glass is the history i'm exhausted yeah
yeah you don't look exhausted
yo if you guys are gonna have your show
here you gotta have them have a fan in
here are you hot yeah
when they cut this window i thought they
were going to put in a wall unit
i legitimately was like they need an air
conditioner
just a fan just to blow some air yeah i
asked that circulation if he would do
the podcast and he asked about the air
quality down here so i'm going to have
to bring my zoom box in so you mentioned
todd lemisch yes that's todd we talked
about him a lot oh you do yeah todd uh
you never met him probably oh i did
i am at him towards the end i have the
creepiest todd story funny i love him i
don't know who this is from philadelphia
he was he was this dude he apparently
sold blow
uh that's how i i got to hang out with
robin williams because i knew that todd
sold him blow at one point and uh so i
just heard these stories about the todd
there's a photo of the todd and robin
williams
hanging up in the front hallway yeah
yeah and uh so
people would talk about him and then one
night this lady showed up old lady and
she's like i'm the todd's mom and i'm
like what wow and uh and she's like todd
was hanging out with don barris and he's
he's now
escaped
in charge of him and then let him go
because he's a jackass yeah apparently
the todd has some mental issues he had a
lot like a breakdown right so he uh
his mom is like if he comes here please
call us whatever i'm like all right dean
was the manager at the time dean's like
yeah we'll call you so at the end of the
night as the doorman i had to go shut
the power off in the main room so i went
back to turn the switch it's a scary
task
so i go back there and it's a dark main
room we didn't have shows in there back
then maybe just on saturday nights i
guess but i walked back stage and i went
to turn the fuses off and i turned the
light on in the green room and there's
just a dude with the beard standing in
the corner facing the corner
and i was so [ __ ] scared and i was i
literally ran out as i am
and i was like i go dean there's uh
there's a guy who looks kind of uh crazy
in the main room and he's like that's
the todd bro call his bomb calling
himself i'm not calling his mom
i don't know his mom i'm not turning the
lights off either lights stay on as long
as the todd's in the corner yeah can i
just say thank you for being the first
black guy to come down here everyone has
turned us down because they're afraid
based on the basement
leslie jones
she straight i was like i'm not going in
the basement i mean it is scary yeah
like like even when the hallway's packed
i've always looked at that graded thing
yeah okay you used to have the and then
the recording and the recording this is
all the scary stories yeah there is no
scary stories in the basement
it didn't look great from up there we
used to have to clean it out mitch used
to make us clean everything in here and
look you know what was that store stuff
down here just just old [ __ ] it's a lot
of [ __ ] did you ever give any haunted
stories have you ever experienced that
[ __ ] here people always ask me about
that i'm like i don't hear anything yeah
i never saw how about in crest hill no
even downstairs because jason hart said
no offense but there was a black guy
that he used to fight in the middle of
the night
i'm trying to measure who's more racist
right now paulie or eleanor you're stuck
in the middle of stuck in the middle
philadelphia usually wins on racism
it's this way all right
no but he said he lived in the bottom
part where you used to live in crest
hill that
custody i live in the bottom part i'm
sorry in the basement yeah i didn't live
in the basement i lived in the main
house
yeah i partied and then i've dreamed my
do you know what i'm talking about where
the uh they had the pool table down yeah
that was yeah yeah yeah so he lived down
there yeah and uh he said he would be
woken up and we were sleeping together
for a while because sometimes i hit rock
bottom you slept with like four people
on just this podcast
[ __ ] there's only three down here
uh but anyway so we used to hang out up
there me freddy soto corey and jason and
he when he would wake up in the middle
of night punching and i'm like the [ __ ]
are you doing and he's like there's this
[ __ ] black guy i'm like i don't know
what's worse but in cresto he said that
was that haunted
who who did you just mention jason
hearts no the other one oh freddie
cory how is she doing corey's good yeah
yeah how's the baby the baby is 15 14.
out of the closet oh it's awesome
that's how old that baby is yeah she's
out it's all freddy
damn
she she does look a little bit looks
ready oh so freddie
she's 14. she just turned 14 july uh
22nd all right yeah
what is she doing now corey
cory's just being corey crazy how did
she make money um
she's always princess cory
for wardrobe not pa like in the wardrobe
compartment that's cool she was doing
stuff like that so that was good yeah so
i was keeping her busy it's good union
work
she has to do so much time before she
gets in the union so it's become like a
pain in the ass but she's getting closer
that's good yeah so yeah she's always
been very crazy
creative oh creative yeah
she had the best you know how like
well no what happened is that front bar
oh yes the front
yeah the front bar
has gone through so many different like
you know uh bartenders or whatever i
know you you try and keep them
attractive ladies up there which i
appreciated in my day yeah yeah i mean
we we were doing that when we first
opened that box yeah because before you
know when we opened the bar was 2005
yeah because that's when we did mining
the store
what do you mean remember
it was closed for the longest time no
was that always like it wasn't really
usable like my mom didn't really
because we used it was a bar but it
wasn't
really open and like
i guess the word is invitati
inviting yeah okay yeah cause corey used
to decorate it and choose to put her big
tits out yeah she used to try hard she
did like candies and yep yep
cigarettes she brings cigarettes
one time she had a brick of cocaine back
there so he asked me to hold it for him
and i was like whoo and then she
mentioned this guy and i'm like are you
out of your face hey where's magic
which one magic
i don't know that one really i don't
know that was sam kennison's drug dealer
imagine i sam
passed in 92 so i missed his error when
i came here um i remember your mom and a
couple other people sitting in the main
room and they were like oh you can't
leave til mitzi leaves and i was the new
waitress so i had to stay i was like
[ __ ] so it was it was like three in the
morning and no they're not moving so i'm
like what what could they be doing in
there and it was a year anniversary i
didn't know i didn't but i was just i
just kept bringing drinks and kept my
mouth shut and but the managers i'd be
like what the [ __ ] are they doing
uh yeah people are gonna trip on my doc
dude i cannot wait to tell her
i got everyone i got like malik malika
oh you found how she's in new york right
she's um
no she lives in nebraska somewhere with
her i think it's her either husband or
boyfriend okay but i got her to i talked
about her first time to tell her version
well that's a good story which was cool
and
and it's great yeah she's awesome she
sounds great yeah people say that your
your mom
hated that you were on the road with sam
is that yeah is that accurate why
well because he was wild yeah but he was
also your babysitter
he wasn't never my baby steve moore and
lois bromfield yeah oh i thought he was
your babysitter the although stories
about who
like people are always like well you
know dave letterman used to take paulie
to baseball practice what he went there
but he wasn't like it's always like it's
always like a full-time your full-time
name jay leno was mike binder i'll tell
you who they was like mike binder argus
ollie joe prater
biff maynard
uh tim thomason alan bersky
we're gonna have him on he's the best
he's out of his mind i love him he's the
best yeah he okay next week oh he's
[ __ ] the king yeah yeah he's
hilarious do you know that in the middle
of one of dice's specials he yells out
jerk off bersky just for no reason like
randomly
he was like the guy at the club
that you always saw walking towards you
and you're like oh [ __ ] and you ran the
other way
but but
or were you afraid what was no you
weren't afraid you just didn't want to
engage in any conversations with the guy
he was just like i don't want to say the
annoying guy at the comedy store but
you know he was but very lovable but he
was just like oh god he was always the
guy coming up he's going to take a lot
of energy
yeah a lot of people listen so it's
tough for me to interact with uh people
now that i'm sober
because i'm i'm basically here mostly on
the weekends and people are so hammered
i can only deal with the non-hammered
people
what made you sober
what's that what made you sober diabetes
diabetes yeah that's a good sober yeah
our guest always said well you're lucky
you got diabetes i'm like i don't know
if i'm lucky
well your doctor told you i had to quit
i wish i had that like yeah it really
seems like a worse thing because you
could still die if you keep drinking
yeah
did you ever drink like were you a
drinker no i stopped drinking when i was
seven
seven yeah it's different in jamaica
yeah so you don't drink at all no not
even a beer no
really i'm with you
i'm good do you still drink some
sometimes yeah do you smoke pot or
anything like that sometimes i remember
it's first time now that dean's like
missed your marijuana man oh you smoke
pot sometimes proud of you good how
about you yeah i do mushrooms okay do
you do mushrooms yeah yeah yeah just
jump this have you have you done have
you done atawaska no not yet i'm gonna
do that you're gonna do it you're gonna
go somewhere to do it i don't know i've
been talking a couple shamans
there's different places and you know
i've do you have to go somewhere and do
it or is it like something it's just
recommended
it's kind of like you know you ever see
those cults you know where there's
someone in charge and you're like
there's people around and you keep
everyone right you don't throw up and
[ __ ] yeah chelsea did it on her show
chelsea handler i think yeah she had
like four people or something and they
went and they did it
uh but they didn't affect them
but she does a lot of drugs that's
amazing she's just she's she built up a
tolerance tolerance for ayahuasca one of
the most powerful
it's hilarious i don't know if i could
do it
are you afraid to do it are you excited
no i want to do it
we were in what do you want to do where
we're at sorry man
um just let go of anything that's
holding me back in my life in the past
you know
with my family
you know like we all kind of let go of
stuff but we all kind of not let go hold
on to some things yeah just you know
i think it's it's like almost like you
know just an emotional dump right yeah i
want to do it so i can let go of the
[ __ ] i'm going to hold on to in the
future
i like to get do my homework early you
know what i'm saying smart get it out
the way oh you don't wait till sunday
night no you're not a weekend
there was we were in i can't remember
where we were it was like brownsville
texas we were in some shitty places i
was on the road with you awesome and uh
brownsville was the best i was uh
shittier the better yeah i i was sharing
a room a chair room with the bodyguard
tyrell
and so we had that guy we had some guy
at the show told us he'd bring us pot
and we're like all right cool and the
the kid he gets out to our hotel
and he's like hanging out and the
trail's like how old are you man
and he's like 17 and he's like man you
got to get the [ __ ] out of our hotel
room
and the dude is like hey man i got some
uh what's that stuff you smoke that
makes you hallucinate for like two
minutes
i can't think of what it's called hash
no it's not pot it basically makes you
like trip
and uh it's like some roots leaves or
something yeah so
yeah i think it is so anyway the the
dude's like bust some of this stuff out
and he hits it and we think he's loading
pot and then he's like hey you guys want
to hit the salvia and we were like i i
didn't know what it was i was pretty
into the drug scene i'm like no and the
dude hits it and then he just starts
laughing and then he falls on the ground
and this is after trail's already told
he has to leave and then trail's like
man what the [ __ ] is wrong with you he's
like i'm tripping man there's blood all
over your carpet
that's good
you got to get the [ __ ] out you just
grab the dude and pull them into the
hallway yeah dude i got i got one store
i'm going to say and i'm going to roll
because i got to get some sleep
so do you remember john cartanelli of
course
tell the audience who he is and then i
gotta tell you the story and then i
gotta go john cardinale is a guitar
comic oh no not that guy john cappanera
no john [ __ ] what was his name [ __ ]
you know who he was [ __ ] john
simone younger no like in that age yeah
yeah cardinal john no no not john
carnelly anyways so i'm on the road oh
you're talking about jonathan gotsick oh
yes god's sake
on the bus yes yes yeah i remember
because terrell called me while he's in
the woods yes he's like hey you said
this guy was all right please tell the
story yeah i love gothic he's a teacher
now
do you ever talk to him uh my jason
hearts does sometimes you gotta ask him
about the story i have to so we're on
the road where i'm on this is when i'm
on using the tour bus
thing
and
[ __ ] i think ba bob
steve simone
simone's featuring
got is it got sick yeah gotham
it's opening and we're in
macon georgia and i got to get to
atlanta overnight because i have radio
okay i'm very serious about my past and
business i'm like we gotta go so we're
at the bar or whatever
after the gig and we get on the bus and
we start watching like
you know sam kennison videos we watch
like that we watch the uh the de niro
video where he plays a comic
oh yeah uh
king of comedy king of comedy
yeah and we're all watching it and he's
in in all of a sudden we're all of a
sudden nowhere the front door and we're
driving down the [ __ ] we're driving
down the uh it's on the interstate yeah
on the interstate and we're going fast
and doesn't gossip like he starts asking
you questions about like encino man or
something or he wanted to know something
about filming yeah they're just like
i don't know all i remember is like
we're sitting there watching [ __ ] you
know we're on the bus and the front door
opens and he jumps off the bus
he jumps off the bus
he kicks the door or heard the story
yeah he kicks the door open
and then the bus driver starts trying to
slow down and he bails out like 35 miles
you know it's like more it's like 50.
yeah he just jumps off the bus dude and
we're in the middle of [ __ ] nowhere
in the middle of the night yeah in the
middle of the night like three in the
morning or some [ __ ] so then the bus
pulls over and he goes in the woods and
then luckily we have a cell phone uh-huh
you know and i'm pissed i'm like i got
radio this is [ __ ] yeah
hilarious like this guy yeah radio i
don't know but he's like disrespecting
the tour like my phone rings and i see
it's tyrell and we're buddies at this
point so i answer i'm like what's up man
he's like
man your friend is [ __ ] up like what
you don't know he's talking about paulie
yeah
he's like
he goes
he jumped off the bus on the highway
and now paulie's got me and walking
around the woods in the south looking
for this dude
i would have [ __ ]
like forget it so we get him we finally
get him and then like at this point like
he's on the other side of the [ __ ]
road yeah and he's miles down he goes to
like a a rest stop or no no no no no we
finally get him because we call him like
dude
no one's trying to hurt you like we
gotta go dude where the [ __ ] are you and
he's like and he gets back on the bus
okay and he looks like he's [ __ ] up
because he's got twigs and [ __ ] or
whatever he did right yeah and then
we're driving again and [ __ ] he jumps
off the bus again dude and we have to
look from another two hours or whatever
yeah and at this point the bus driver is
like dude no we can't do it we can't we
can't this is like a live so we finally
get him
finally somehow we find him i don't know
how in the woods
you know what i mean
and then tyrell's in the front of the
bus and we just pull off at the other
the next exit
hotel right a motel yeah lock him in
there and just be like and then i guess
his brother went to pick him up or
something right his brother goes and
picks him up and then and strangely
enough after that
gossip decided he probably shouldn't
perform at the comedy store anymore no
and he was a door guy here for a long
time
he was very funny
he had some great bits i i i liked
gossip and i was friends with him but
he legitimately seemed crazy after that
and he's a teacher now he's a teacher
obviously he's doing great no but he is
just saying
uh your favorite teacher because um but
you uh you took a lot of those guys on
the tour on tour with you like you took
jason hearts and do you remember getting
stuck in a storefront on hollywood
boulevard with him
and you guys were peeking under and you
kept telling people tell me what he
looks like you said you were stuck under
there with adam sandler because he kind
of looked like oh that jason hearts
loved that guy he was the best
my mom loved him
the penny she didn't love him oh she
didn't no because jason was because he
was kind of fumbling no he was cheap and
like if she would ask him to do
something he'd be like i i clocked out
and so he would flock in
back in to do something for him
and she would call him the penny
so oh the penny pincher is here
i always thought was weird about dean
was when i worked here we got 25 dollars
a night that's it so you'd work like an
eight hour shot to work the door
so like you'd work an eight hour shift
and you just got 25 bucks and it worked
out to be like three dollars an hour or
something terrible
and despite the fact that it was a set
pay i would i would get my uh
i'd clock in clock in clock out or
whatever and dean would shave hours
off
and be like no bro
it's illegal otherwise
that's that's not a reason to do it you
should just pay us more right now bro
you get stage time i'll see you guys
next time
i got 11 o'clock spot but i don't know
how much they're gonna be on time up
there well we'll tell them to get some
air in here it's down here if uh
i would i can't i'm sorry we just we
talked to him he was like yeah well
let's do it right now
all right let's do it right now
i would have been here earlier but i got
stuck at largo
oh no three minutes oh okay perfect wow
three minutes
we'll be right in an hour so that works
out well
i don't know they're never on time they
did it last week too and they're like
rick we need you i'm like but my spot's
actually supposed to start now so can
you put someone else up yeah they put up
hinchcliffe who looked so happy up there
just being evil as [ __ ] yeah he's next
here i don't want to make him happy yeah
absolutely not don't i don't make sure
you get up there i'm going to go for it
i'm going up before you tony it's not
happening what we'll do is we'll just
have you back if you want yeah i'm done
because i feel bad that we um because
you got you got to get a lot of good
stories
i can't believe you talked to me for
that long i'm going to be honest
i brought
but it's true but i'm excited to
interview you for real all right i'm
excited that um you came all right
because you know we had some color in
the basement it's so exciting yeah
i'm like she's not kidding multiple
people
they've all said no they're like if you
bring the stuff up here i'm like but the
studio is down there don't worry i'll
tell them it's not all right thank you
you were all right everyone was accurate
in your decision to not go in the
basement
it is crazy jones the actual ghostbuster
will not come down here that's [ __ ]
hilarious that is [ __ ] amazing all
right i'll see you all next time thank
you yeah thanks thanks for being here
ian thanks to paulie shore yes double
dip
dip dip dip
anyway um ricky yeah for coming in yeah
interesting it definitely was uh an
interesting episode i'm glad we got to
record it and i hope it recorded yeah me
too and if not
if not then you know the goat
for the ages the ghosts will have loved
every second of it [ __ ]
all right yeah i'm rick ingram
thanks for listening comedystore podcast
guys come see a show
so
you